well hello Queens okay first of all I
have to ask were you guys both fans of
each other before getting on set to work
we were we can now admit it because
we've admitted it to each other we
weren't total fans of each other and
then getting to meet each other it was
even better than I thought it was just
like instant chemistry so much respect
and we just we had a blast yeah
I love that sure at least for you you've
been in a lot of iconic films but
they're not exactly kid friendly so what
is this like for you to have your
daughters be able to watch you in this
are they excited yeah they they watch
they've seen it already
um they saw they saw a rough cut uh
while I was shooting this film out in
Rome over the summer
and uh it was uh it was a highlight I
gotta you know I gotta be honest there's
definitely uh I've lived my whole life
kind of like with a tough exterior you
know I don't care I don't need that and
this was definitely a moment where I was
like
sure it's it's it was a huge um reason
why I wanted to do it
yeah Carrie for you you said that the
idea of working with Charlize was the
most exciting for you but did she live
up to the height she did she really did
what if you were like not really no she
didn't I mean also just when you're are
working with somebody who you share so
much you know being working moms that's
just it immediately gives you this
Common Ground a shared language and the
fact that the material is about raising
incredible kids or about kids finding
out how amazing they are on their own
Journey which is parents were there to
kind of help them along that Journey not
get in the way of them knowing how
amazing they are so it was really it was
really fun and she is incredible and
um really fun to work with and inspiring
how much do I have to pay you now I know
it's like this is not cracking oh it's
racking up oh my God this is definitely
going to turn into a franchise so for
your future franchise who would be a
celeb friend that you would love to join
the cast oh oh that's a fun question
I I I but it's maybe just because I just
talked about him but taika would be
really funny yeah yeah he would be fun
in this world yeah I think I don't know
why probably because they just they just
I feel like James and I need a trifecta
so I would say Jamie Foxx maybe because
we gotta finish our three yeah you
really should yeah yeah and he would be
so bad in this world yeah yeah
uh so man thinks Angelina Jolie and Paul
thinks Jennifer Lawrence how are we
feeling about that I mean anyone's
welcome and when and what time yeah
exactly I shall be there come on yes
that's amazing yes
and what school would you guys be in the
school for good or the school for evil
I think we it's dependent I mean I think
different periods of my life
my 20s for sure evil evil
when I was younger I think I was
definitely in the school for good
yeah it just depends I mean I guess it's
like what the movie really is about
right it's the fact that it's not so
one-dimensional and yeah it's a little
bit more complicated and there's a
little bit of both uh in all of us
um
yep I think I think both can be fun yeah
you need both I think you need both to
be balanced as a human being you know
you gotta you gotta know what the rules
are and be willing to like live within
them but also be willing to break them
when appropriate
I like it thank you guys appreciate your
time